Radical right wing radio host Rush
Limbaugh, in many ways the father of modern
right wing political media in in we could say
that actually in a number of different ways,
has died at the age of 70 from lung
cancer, which we learned about a year ago
that he had. You may recall that shortly after
his diagnosis, Donald Trump awarded him the
Presidential Medal of Freedom during the State of
the Union address in the year 2020. He has died
and this has brought out it's really brought out
the worst of many people, but also understandable
ire and in a sense, relief that Rush Limbaugh
will no longer be on the American airwaves.
And I've received so many emails about this, some
people gleeful at the death of Rush Limbaugh,
others more circumspect. And I want to be sort of
super clear. I don't believe in participating in
cheering people's illness or death, nor do I ever
wish illness or death upon anyone. And at the same
time as adults, most of us, we can recognize that
some people have a positive influence in the world
and some people have a negative influence in
the world. And Rush Limbaugh's influence on
the world was disgustingly and decidedly and
unquestionably negative and disastrously so.
Rush Limbaugh used to do a segment where he
would celebrate when people with AIDS died,
as written by Mary Strom Larssen, quote, He
garnered a following with outrageous programing
that includes such features as celebratory
moments when another AIDS victim died,
which he called AIDS updates. That
is disgusting. It knows no bounds.
That is that is lower than anything. He regularly
referred to women who I guess believe in women's
rights as feminazi as he regularly took pleasure
in the death of people on the left. Here he is,
Rush Limbaugh, gleeful at the death of former
Supreme Court Justice Ruth Bader Ginsburg,
just ecstatic the possibility that it presents for
the right to further take over the Supreme Court.
Washington Post has a story that Democrats
largely powerless to stop the GOP
from confirming their court choice.
Folks, do you know how big this is?
This is huge, this could be.
I want to whisper this the end of Roe versus Wade,
but this is going to have a massive impact on
the American judiciary, thus going to have a
massive impact on American culture and society.
So this is absolutely an endlessly disgusting. So,
listen, I've been seeing the posts. I've been
getting the messages, I've been seeing the
tweets of people essentially doing a dance
on Rush Limbaugh's grave. That's not in my
constitution to do that just doesn't
feel right. And so I don't do it.
When Rush Limbaugh was diagnosed
with lung cancer, I didn't hear
Rush Limbaugh has a family. I don't know if he
has kids. I guess maybe he does. I mean, listen,
he he's a terrible he was a terrible person, but
illness and death affect people. And I would never
wish that on anyone. But there is no doubt that
we can recognize this person was an absolutely
terrible influence on American politics. He
was responsible for much of the not just,
you know, coarsening of language is sort
of like, OK, coarsening of language,
but the normalization of a certain type of
guttersnipe being politics during his early days
on radio and the world was what was negatively
affected by his presence on the airwaves.
So Rush Limbaugh dead at 70. And those
are my thoughts. And quite frankly,
I don't I don't feel the need to say too much
more about it. But I do want to talk a little
bit about Donald Trump's bizarre, rambling,
self-centered eulogy for Rush on Fox News